hello and welcome to gamespot of Thrones
you are watching just a small segment of
a much larger program where we discuss
in depth Game of Thrones season 6
episode 1 the red woman if you'd like to
see the full episode be sure to head to
youtube.com slash gamespot beware of
spoilers I've got a prediction to mine
is about Sansa Stark so I know a lot of
people myself included weren't really
very happy with what happened to her in
season 5 so you know season 4 she comes
out of it and she's like a badass she's
working with Littlefinger she's been or
manipulative and then in season 5 she
just you know gets married after Ramsay
and it's just sort of her his punching
bag and then she escapes swear as this
season you know we've been promised that
she's gonna be you know just sort of
reclaim a lot of things be a badass and
she's already been poised as being the
key to the north so I think the way that
her seasons kind of gonna go is that we
know that the moments of Bear Island are
only gonna answer to a stark so she's
also going to Castle black with Breanna
and pod because she knows that's where
John is she's heard that's what John is
so she needs to go find some families
find some find some help but I think she
doesn't know that John's dead so when
she gets there she's actually just gonna
find Davos who she's gonna ally with so
she's gonna get on board immediately
Davos like the loyal members of the
Nights Watch and the wildlings and with
wildlings comes Giants so I think
unintentionally Sansa is gonna become
just basically queen of the north and do
a way better job of it than Rob ever did
because Rob just sort of was immature
didn't think ended up marrying someone
and you know basically costing half his
family whereas I think Santa has been
through so much and she's learned from
so many people she is basically we're
gonna become the boss ass [ __ ] of the
north and take on the Bolton's I think
that's what's gonna happen with her Kate
what do you think I think she's never
gonna trust anyone again and I think
that's definitely a good thing in Game
of Thrones like if you remember back to
season one little finger says to Ned you
should never have trusted me and
the whole point that's the whole point
of Game of Thrones is just don't trust
anyone even Cersei shouldn't be trusting
Jamie mm-hmm so I think she's in a good
position to be queen of the north Dave
it's a great theory I can't wait to see
here in davao side by side what a dream
team mmm I'm gonna cause some damage
some some well jus damage the Bolton's
oh yeah so hopefully we'll see you back
in her old home Winterfell pretty soon
the badass [ __ ] this years so I know
that Ramses also on his way to Castle
black but we've also seen in the
trailers there is like a massive
confrontation outside Winterfell so I'm
not entirely sure if their paths will
cross then or if Ramsay i'll just send
you know his 20 good man up to do his
dirty work for him but I'm really
excited for that big confrontation
outside Winterfell
you